The base of which China's cooperation with
Europe is growing.
Is higher and greater than
that of the growth of Chinese Russian cooperation.
Ask Europeans,
aren't they afraid?
They might be.
I don't know.
But they are still trying to access China's market
at all costs.
Especially now that they are facing economic problems.
Chinese businesses
are also exploring the European market.
Do Chinese businesses have small presence in
the United States?
Yes. The political decisions are such
that they are trying to limit
their cooperation with China.
It is to your own detriment,
Mister Tucker,
that you are limiting cooperation with China.
You're hurting yourself.
It is a delicate matter,
and there are no silver bullet solutions.
Just as it is with the dollar